hello
hi welcome to the thing
my name is hans kim i'm here with james
schrader
san diego comic
and
podcaster podcaster commercial actor
father divorcee are you in podcasting i
have a podcast we have not started that
podcast like putting out the podcast i'm
actually in the process of building my
podcast studio if you will
uh back in san diego so it's fun yeah
i'm enjoying it i should have been doing
it do you do other people's podcasts
when i can there's not a ton going on in
san diego but yeah what's the biggest
podcast in san diego
um
as far as comedians go
probably
dustin nickerson's podcast awesome and
he only does that with his wife so you
can't even do it it's just he and his
wife talking that's fun yeah it's got
like big on the lonely housewife market
yeah i think so i mean they got a heck
of a following dustin's doing great uh
do you know dustin do you know so he's
been favoring with um taylor tomlinson a
bunch and he went on bert christopher's
tour on the buses the
birdie whatever whichever tour that was
nice and yeah so he's been doing that's
awesome that's the same uh thing that
brian simpson was on correct yeah we're
on the if you saw the side of the bus
where they all have bert's body
and their heads yeah that's that one i
haven't seen the bus yeah did was it was
it in san diego you guys all went or
um what do you mean to the show or how
do you know what the bus looks like i
mean well just like burt's social media
i saw
so yeah i don't even know if they came
to san diego
yeah
that seems like a [ __ ] awesome show
with shane gillis oh my god joey diaz
yeah and simpson yeah with like taylor
and dustin and i know they all kind of
like some were coming and going from the
tour at different times but you know i
mean that's
it's bert so it's a party you know
you know it's gonna be fun does he drink
with the comics oh yeah i think he just
drinks he just drinks and everyone else
is there didn't mark norman go on tour
with him and he had to quit because it
was like too much drinking i think so i
think that came out but then that's
another thing is like you see all these
pictures
of these guys and like the next morning
they're all sitting there getting ivs
and getting hydrated professionally so
they can go out and do it again the next
day yeah i did that what's that like
like you actually feel like can you feel
i felt better
it wasn't like noticeably better where
you hung over to stop i wasn't feeling
shitty no i wasn't that hungover you
were oh okay i was just sort of normal
it's just crazy because you see this bag
over your head and all that is going in
your body right and you can't do
anything to stop it and it's just like
sitting there but it's good like you
want that it's good stuff the best thing
yeah but it's like a bag of more like
here carry this and you got that in your
bloodstream you just got water in your
blood or whatever that it's water and
electrolytes and vitamins and i'm sure
they like now they it's funny if you
look them up you can they get like the
b12 additives and vitamin c crazy
dosages and yeah if you got the money i
mean it's probably an amazing thing to
do so
what do you got
hopefully it's
is it live are we even happening
it doesn't
uh let me check on the
check it gmail
if you're oh like so this is going live
on where on youtube yeah
let me start
uh
technical hopefully it's been gone now
or it hasn't it doesn't matter i mean
you know yeah so do you even record this
or you just start it live whenever it
happens to happen
uh i usually just do it live and then it
happens and that's that there it is
hmm
interesting well i'm recording it
let me stop recording
uh sorry that's all right do you
i don't know if it's going out
let me stop streaming
h-a-n-s yeah there we go
we'll go to your channel
videos
i don't see anything saying it's live or
that there is a live thing
channels about
live
nope
okay well it's recording
so how have you been
uh pretty good you know i mean i'm here
that's exciting yeah awesome i've never
i've never technically came through town
like 10 years ago yeah uh but that was
for like one night nine it was really
before before comedy was even a thing
for me really but um
but now i'm here and it's great to see
the guys and you know i haven't seen
i haven't really spent time with assange
or derrick in a couple years at least
and brian too how long have you been
doing comedy
10 years
10 years what about you where'd you
start nine years nine years uh seattle
and how long were you there before
three in new york one here what was new
york like it was amazing
why'd you move here
because there was a pandemic and just
everything they were shut down
well yeah it was like death and
destruction it was like in uh
2020 when i moved out
so it was like right there in the middle
of it i used to live in a van and i was
on a road trip
to miami and then that [ __ ] happened
so then i just escaped
i was i was in miami anyway so then i
went to seattle then i went to la and
then i went camping in the joshua tree
area beautiful yeah it was amazing yeah
i saw your van so how long have you had
your van
four years
and that was the plan i'm gonna build it
out i'm gonna live and live in it in new
york
in the city yeah so you were just like
moving it from
[Music]
zero rent in new york city right near
manhattan and had a pretty comfortable
place i mean the van could stand up
was it it had a heater was it sketchy at
all like did you were you ever kind of
worried about people outside the van or
messing with the van or i was worried
about like nosy neighbors and like you
know homeowners associations or whatever
right
the equivalent is in new york but yeah
no did you ever get like evicted from
your space like technically it was legal
right like
if it's by the book i think people like
sort of
in new york everyone minds their own
business a lot
because if you care about other people
you're gonna spend all day caring so
you're just like whatever do it do you
just don't let it affect my life right
and so as long as you weren't like
trashing the area they didn't care if a
van was sitting there because it's i
mean that's the funny thing with new
york is like like a van like yours one
it doesn't look like a camping van it
doesn't look like you're living like it
looks like it used to be a plumbing
truck or something and it's probably
still being used to run deliveries
around there's nothing on the outside i
resisted the urge to put any stickers on
it or paint it or anything
which would have been extra money right
goes against the whole philosophy of the
van yeah but but even it draws attention
that's the one thing it's like which
path are you going are you trying to
live in a city and be incognito or are
you trying to be like i'm living the van
life and watch my journey on youtube
which i i fully support i mean i love
the idea of it but you were doing it in
real life for a show
yeah that's fun
but you didn't do that you were like no
i'm just trying to not pay you i would
have if i could have i don't have that
skill of like being able to film myself
and people find it inherently
interesting
why why do you think that is i don't i
think it's a skill i think some people
are good at it i don't think it's just
natural i think if you want to get good
at it you can if you work at it like mr
beast yeah
but i don't think necessarily everyone's
born out the womb being able to
communicate via youtube
what about in general like i mean here's
the interesting part i know who you are
because i've heard you brought up on
rogue and i've heard it like you've
opened for rogan and like done tour like
shows with him yeah but i've never seen
your comedy but in the
total of 35 minutes maybe we've been in
the same room for the first time ever
you're very chill you're very kind of
monotone you're very you know like
would you agree yeah i'm robotic i have
no emotions
why but do you i mean you feel
you feel on the inside definitely okay
you just don't emote
why is that
uh
well i think asian culture is like built
around
uh long-term survival and boring
you know
[ __ ] another what is that what do you
mean by born like long-term survival i
get it's like no energy no testosterone
it's just all meekly getting by life
with the least amount of energy possible
okay but yet you chose to do comedy
which is a very
performance
based
in front of stand-up
alpha maneuver
yeah masculine maneuver from the
standpoint of like it's an alpha thing
to do to get on stage and then command
200 or 2 000 people's attention and you
do that well clearly i do it with the
asian method so i do like an
alpha thing
by being a beta it's like explain
like i'm meekly
you know just like going up there and
doing it and it's like i'm doing like
uh like being the best beta
instead of i don't know but it's like
asian [ __ ] it's like i i don't want to
display any emotions because that might
cause trouble for for like is it cause
trouble or is it like i don't want to
put my emotions on you so i just don't
emote emotion at all yeah it's a it's a
different way of interacting with people
it's like as far as the way you've said
it is an asian way of being here is my
offering of sentence and you can accept
or deny but i'm not trying to get in
there and trying to mess with your
wiring or plumbing
uh but i think americans are just like
let me get in there [ __ ] mind meld
all my feelings and all my i'm gonna
dump it on you and make you kind of deal
with my how are you doing oh well you
know
the cat died again
where if somebody asks you how are you
doing what's your answer if your cat
died uh
nothing to worry about to hear and then
you ate the cat
yeah the cat's been cooked yeah it's all
a ploy to eat more cats
so well then how so you grew up in a
very asian like very deep asian culture
like where
where was that pretty asian um i mean i
was born in new jersey
but my mom and dad were asian
what type of asian korean okay yeah
um
yeah asia was a part of my life where
was where you grew up was it a large
asian community so you were like within
it there was like a church
and we all hung out a lot right hands
yeah and that's like multiple nights a
week like isn't that a thing sometimes
yeah
and so but like were you like around
like i i i it's just like such an excuse
to hang out it's like we have to pretend
jesus exists so that we can see other
koreans and not any of our emotions by
the way there's no like what are we
gonna have a book club
it's like
i don't know it's like practical and
mm-hmm it's
like yeah it requires a suspension of
disbelief and then people are like oh
you're just here to make friends then
they don't respect you because you know
you're not religious enough whatever
that means so then there's a competition
of how religion you are how religious
you are yeah so that's interesting
because you're saying this stuff is like
oh the asian way is like we don't put
our emotions out we're very just we
we're survivalists we're not putting our
stuff on other people yeah yet you're
faking religion as you put it to make
friends and be social but then what do
you even say some people are okay were
your parents those people like were you
no my parents were true believers i
think so they were the mo they were the
ones judging the others yeah
was that
do you still believe no
how'd that go how old were you when you
were like this ain't it
like middle school high school in the
day what happened with them
i just sort of just coasted just
you know like g like bill burr's bit
where he's like it's like curling on the
seventh day
[Laughter]
but how did your parents take that did
they i didn't really tell them you just
stopped going to church with them yeah
that's how little i respect it
i was like you don't need it's all
[ __ ] oh i yeah i believe but what
about so that's how little you respect
the religion side or apparently
the religion
which you know i uh i have conflicting
thoughts on but yeah it's like
the religion is sort of like
uh if it's not real
then why would i make it a big deal
who was saying it's not real because if
you're going to this thing and your
parents are true believers then to them
it's real do you think they believe it's
real they're true true like this is the
word of god and this i don't know it's
been a while in the 90s it was easier to
be a true believer
that's when i grew up but i think now
i mean
i don't know how you you could but i'm
i'm sure that like you know it's i don't
know i'd have to ask them
so that didn't that hasn't really come
up
what do they think about you doing
comedy i mean this is considering how
how
uh what's the word how
uh i can't think of it but just
traditional it seems like from an asian
standpoint you grew up
with the culture comedy is not usually
it's like you know you're going to be a
doctor you're going to be at this you
need to
excel and succeed
what did they think when you were like
i'm comedy
um well i had uh been caught shoplifting
and been suspended for a semester in
college
and they were like i got fired from my
job and i was living with my mom and i
would come home at like 1am and she'd be
like where were you
this is the first night i went to a mic
it's like you're going down a bad path
and then i was like i was out of comedy
i'm going to do comedy now
okay
and then she never asked about it again
just let you keep doing it yeah first of
all what did you steal what did you
shoplift uh like a bowl like plates a
little computer mouse uh i put it all in
a backpack and i was gonna walk out what
store excuse me sir target target an
atlantic station
in atlanta
which these don't seem like it's you
know like this is like kind of necessity
stuff like you needed a bowl you needed
some
some cutlery in it
the most inefficient thing to steal in
terms of
per square inch per cubic inch
that's kind of bulky items yeah
okay and then you got the cop stopped
you grabbed you yeah full arrest full
yeah jail overnight no
well into the night like midnight
your parents bail jail
or they just released uh
i forget who bailed me out
i don't think there was a bail i think i
was i went into pre-trial convictions or
whatever they were like we know you did
it you did it just so you did it i was
it was like a black thing a lot of
blacks there
and i was like the asian guy yeah like i
didn't fit in so they like gave me
pre-trial diversion like get out of get
out of here wait we don't want to get on
the news
because they gave me like the white
people pass i think that's i don't know
if that was really the case but that's
how it felt at the time yeah they're
like you don't belong here you're gonna
get murdered in here and we don't want
to be held responsible so just go
because you're not black
anyways got out of that jail
and then i paid a lawyer the same lawyer
that defended
travis mcmichaels against ahmad albree
oh okay
uh but yeah he was uh my lawyer and he
got me
off with community service that i didn't
even fully do i just forged a document
okay is somebody knocking yeah could you
can you let him in arenas thank you
all right so that's that's it was it
took an arrest for you to decide
comedy is now the thing yeah
that's all it's gonna pop in the fourth
mic
right right over there we're gonna shift
things through the middle a little bit
hopefully it's working now
you wanna try to squeeze that chair
so you want both of you on this camera
then
yeah turn this out
yeah thanks man yeah how's it going good
i saw you yesterday walking out of uh
the rogan pin man oh nice you were busy
uh
do you uh you have a is there another
chair down there that's not that high no
no or not that i saw
james by the way
i don't know why this isn't working